surveillance cameras capturing a U-Haul
barreling down a sidewalk with police in
a Hot Pursuit as you can see one man
makes a last-ditch effort to try to
avoid being run over and we are learning
more into what's being described as a
violent Rampage through the streets of
Brooklyn thanks for joining us tonight
at 11 o'clock I'm Denise Valdez and I'm
Brian Loftus one person is dead seven
others injured after 62-year-old Wang
soar allegedly plowed through the
streets of New York City this morning
soar who has ties to Las Vegas is now in
custody Madison Kimbrough Live From The
Newsroom with more store allegedly LED
police on a three-mile long Chase
through the streets of Brooklyn now
while it's unclear who out of the eight
victims is now dead we hear from those
that were in the area when it happened
he was dragging his truck right through
here and he banned that whole entire
bike pole and he kept going but then
there was a cop right behind him
Witnesses describing what they saw
Monday morning when this man 62 year old
Wang soar allegedly plowed through the
streets of Brooklyn in a U-Haul truck
severely injuring multiple people and
killing one seven civilians and one
police officer were hit a man working
nearby dropped everything to rescue his
co-worker when all this happened I just
ran outside and I saw one of my drivers
laying down outside of the crosswalk and
I tried to you know calm him down that's
all I mean it was just a big bang I just
looked her through the window I saw
U-Haul truck and cops the Associated
Press reporting that sore's son admits
his father has a history of mental
illness and would skip his medications
adding that his dad lived in Las Vegas
the 8 news now investigators discovered
court documents and soar has a lengthy
rap sheet take a look he has been cited
for battery three times in five years
stabbing multiple people including his
own brother zor served 16 months for for
two of those stabbings and was not
released on parole then after his third
stabbing served another year in the
Clark County Detention Center soar
rented the truck in Florida last month
and may have been living in it his son
says he showed up in New York
unexpectedly last week
and as of now NYPD doesn't believe this
was a hate crime or act of terrorism but
a chaotic attack on innocent people in
The Newsroom Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Now